Ukrainian president of Vladimir
zielinski is in London on his first UK
trip since the War Began nearly a year
ago zielinski will meet prime minister
Rishi Suna can address Parliament
Britain is one of Ukraine's biggest
military backers and its scented weapons
and equipment worth 2.5 billion dollars
John hulls joining us live from London
Jonah what's the significance of this
particular visit at this time
it's a rare trip away from Ukraine of
course for president zielinski whose
first visit to the UK and coming a
fortnight or so before the anniversary
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine it is
perhaps a recognition and acknowledgment
of Britain's steadfast support for
Ukraine since the invasion cemented of
course by former prime minister Boris
Johnson but very much continued under
Rishi sunak and doubtless an opportunity
for president zielinski not just a
wartime leader but now an absolutely
Relentless campaigner to continue his
campaign for international support for
Ukraine for that support not to wane and
indeed for that support to deepen we
have in the last few minutes or so seen
live pictures of a plane touching down
at Stansted Airport a gray C70 what
looks like a royal Air Force transport
plane carrying president zielinski
that's about an hour by fast-moving
Convoy or so away from West Minster here
where he's first expected to meet the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak at 10 Downing
Street and then at some point itinerary
yet to be confirmed Buckingham Palace
says he will be meeting King Charles III
he's also delivering an address to both
both houses of Parliament inside the
ancient Westminster Hall behind me
that's an occasion Reserve generally for
only the most uh significant and
influential State visitors and then
later he'll finish his day a busy day of
course meeting Ukrainian troops in the
southwest of the country currently being
trained by UK forces under a
multinational training program
Jonah thank you very much indeed just as
you're talking there we can see the live
pictures from London stanson Airport I
counted about at least 10 vehicles in
that Convoy taking president zielinski
to Central London where he's going to be
going through that uh agenda that Jonah
Hull has been talking about